[Music]
hey everybody welcome to education I am
Kevin Smith and I'm Andy McCullough for
hey we have a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] to
give away ladies and gentlemen as we
gather for is this the third time this
little hot can we turn the mics down
just a touch
JC [ __ ] third time we're doing this
third time's a charm it's gonna be good
man we got a lot of cool prizes [ __ ]
Andy has come up with a bevy of
questions to go over a plethora if you
will we'd yet they were where's the box
there it is over there can you just
throw that up how's everybody doing this
evening this afternoon [ __ ] it's early
this is the earliest we've ever done it
two o'clock we're only doing it that way
because I get on a flight tonight a
red-eye to go out to Florida to finish
shooting Kilroy Was Here
or a little horror movies whoo which
ironically enough Andy and I wrote
started as on education as what are we
gonna run this we're gonna do a Krampus
movie comes the cramp comes at all then
everybody was like is it porn we were
like no which is called comes the
Krampus and so we changed it later on
and it became Kilroy Was Here
so that's what we're going to shoot but
here's a little inside [ __ ] dope man
tomorrow like I fly tonight I landed
like five six in the morning and by nine
o'clock we're on set the first performer
I'm shooting with is Andy's daughter
Daisy man Daisy so it's gonna be [ __ ]
amazing for ya for hopefully for her
unless she goes home and she's like he
ruined it I'll never act again no no no
bill she can't wait to work with you and
also she is it's it's a horror movie
yeah it's a totally funny thing well as
a dad your daughter's in the movie yeah
it's a very odd thing to send your
daughter down to be in a movie that's
gonna have blood all over it Shuba your
daughter like my daughter
spoilers gets like killed yeah she had a
a butchery death man and she your
daughter she spoiled
does some killin coming yes it'll be a
long time before like the movies out and
stuff but those are two pretty big
spoilers yeah
but it's it's fun the only problem is I
wish Andy was going but I'm I'm going to
Florida Sarasota is where we're shooting
we work with the folks at the Ringling
College kids at the Ringling College
it's gonna be so [ __ ] hot it will be
very very hot for you sir and I've
changed my look recently like I don't
wear the hockey jerseys anymore I've
taken up jackets again yes so I just
want today and not today I wasn't picked
him up yesterday I bought a bunch of
linen jackets cuz it's gonna be [ __ ]
boiling down there so you're gonna be
like Matlock do all the men wear linen
is that what it is here some lawyers
yeah lawyers so it's a seersucker
seersucker or or linen suit I bought a
about five Jags yesterday one of them I
bought was salmon colored like really
salmon colored wow cuz I was like I'm
going to Florida man I'll fit in with
the old people and [ __ ] so I brought it
home and my wife was like I ain't
[ __ ] you wearing that and then she's
like she goes hold on she called down to
the kid's room she's like get up here
and look at this oh no the kid ran out
man she was like oh my god you're
wearing some and I was like yeah man
trying it out kid was very supportive of
the salmon look wide not so much yeah
she was yeah it was it was kind of
interesting but uh and the whole time
here in Florida you're gonna be like you
know I have a salmon coat at home
because everyone's gonna be wearing
salmon is that what it means it's a very
popular color down there so I'm gonna
wear I'm gonna wear it I'll be wearing
it like almost every day so you will be
about you will be taking it you didn't
listen to your vice to your wife's
advice when have I ever done that
so no I'm definitely bringing the salmon
coat but I'm not really like committed
to it in terms of oh my god it's my nice
jacket like I think my I might have all
the kids right on it at the end of the
show everybody that worked on it that'd
be alright and then I could never have
wear it again yeah through do you make
it the urge to like swim upstream or get
attacked by a bear you took it very
scientific yeah which is good
we're about to get some what scientific
we're about to begin the edge of the pub
quiz ladies gentlemen put your hands
together questions
dandy andrew has put together a full
list of questions banned so get your
cards out in front of you get your pens
or pencils in your hand and stuff as and
no peeking
as per usual phones down
jaren the round as we're asking
questions and until you hand in your
cart your round cards keep your phones
down so don't look like you're looking
up the answer all we ask if this edge of
a pop quiz is that you use the computer
between your eyes that's right don't
pick up your phone try to remember this
[ __ ] everyone can win if they use their
[ __ ] phone right that's true
else but no just the confirmation I was
thinking though that you know the hard
thing about writing these questions I
thought was coming up with stuff that
was hard enough that not everybody would
know it but that somebody in the room
would know the answer to each of the
questions okay and it turns out that the
really hard part is the internet because
they just want to crawl up your ass if
you get a question that's kind of the
answers kind of wrong so I just want to
say this in my defense last week we did
a question about how many you you really
carry across with this yet bad it's
crazy talk about before we got here to
at the house he was like I get the guy
who can get off on a technicality I do I
do it
and I'm like the only way you should be
thinking about getting off is with your
wife stop obsessing over this [ __ ]
game that [ __ ] I'll be right there honey
I'm writing questions actually pretty
smart there's love Jason movies and
there's but he's only the main character
in what I said was 11 and a lot of
people said no it's 10 because in in in
part 5
somebody is pretending to be Jason but
one of the one of the regular listeners
wrote in johnnycakes wrote in on a
private message he said well in all over
the movies somebody's pretending to be
Jason it just happens to be another
character in that movie so I'm taking it
the point being that an actor is always
pretending to play yes yes yeah nobody's
agreeing with me that'll stand up in
court
alright so we're gonna play the first
round ladies gentlemen round one of the
edge of a pop quiz is the
Terry Fox prep round that means the
winner of this round is going to walk
away with not one not two but three sets
of Terry Fox prep gym outfits as worn by
actual actors and actresses in the movie
yoga hosers a movie that I swear does
exist so here we go Matt's five
questions in this round get your cards
out in front of you andis done all the
prep and let's give a round of applause
to Andi for coming up with the brain
murders so nice thank you so much you
get them to applaud now because when you
start asking the tough questions you
gonna be like [ __ ] jerk Andi okay
here we are question number one Terry
Fox Brown is all about high school
movies kids or high school TV shows so
this one is high school movie taglines
taglines we're gonna give you the
tagline you've got to provide the movie
is that it that's that that's the game
we're playing right here here we go
number one tagline he's out to prove
he's got nothing to prove now to prove
he's got nothing to prove he's out to
prove he's got enough to prove I'll be
honest with you I don't know that one oh
you will
thank God I get the answers out of here
that's true we will give the answers out
soon enough
number two tagline watch your back
I'll do the posterior watch your back
fair enough
you're given visual clues yes it's like
a [ __ ] double do what are they le
double video yeah jeopardy you have a
favorite [ __ ] category time on that
show and I used to watch it like oh
they're gonna show a cliff it was
usually a movie clip here we go the next
one number three let's not and say we
did
dramatic let's not and say we did say we
did these are all in IMDb's top 15 high
school movies just so you know it's a
pretty short list
[ __ ] hey man I honestly don't know a
single one of them yet okay number four
sex clothes popularity whatever that one
I think I could get yes I think you've
got that one buddy first one the rest of
stumped okay and number five the fifth
clue and the Terry Fox round the final
clue there's something about your first
piece you're fat when I could guess -
there's something about your first piece
those your first round questions - Terry
Fox round as soon as you finish filling
out your card throw your hands in the
air wave them like you just don't care
and Nate or Big Daddy Jimmy B are gonna
swing by grab those car here we got him
got a lot of glum face family said I
know I don't blame a man I'd be glum as
[ __ ] - is this mine did they put that
there for me thank you
it was tough those are some decent
beyond decent questions yes they were
but if you think about it there each of
them is the tag line is a clue to the
movie and if you had a second to think
about it I think you might have gotten
every single one I was too busy being
the quiz master last chance cards coming
in everybody got cards in counting it
out five seconds five four three no more
cards - all right here we go just like
New Year's Eve five four three two one
we finish the round ladies and gentlemen
we accomplished some [ __ ] okay man
let's get on to the answers okay so the
answer you read the question I'll read
the answer fair enough wish I had to be
fair there are no questions they were
all tag lines right tag line number one
he's out to prove he's got nothing to
prove and that would be
vote for Pedro himself Napoleon Dynamite
nothing2prove fair enough
I didn't know that movie had a tagline I
thought it was too hip for that kind of
well no here we go number two watch your
back who do you have to watch your back
from why Mean Girls that's who oh nice
cool movies that are beyond most of us
not our high school movies our kids high
school moves yeah I mean they're but
they're popular you've seen all these
films not a Christmas more of an
observation
I see number three let's not and say we
did that would be easy eh easy eh with
Emma Stone yes we got some easy a's over
here man
i would never have had that number for
sex clothes popularity whatever i got a
guess clueless clueless is the answer
very good very good
I finally got I'm on the board and then
number five there's something about your
first piece well in this case piece has
two meanings one is sex and the other is
a piece of pie America yeah oh my god
and with joe poutine we've got two teams
that are gonna present a winner man can
we see a representative from both teams
come up here Andy what are those teams
well the first team is three beans in a
Cantina three beans give it up for three
beans here we go hey team is the Sarlacc
stung John get over here somebody
wrapped somebody come on up all right
Ryan stoner everybody what's up so very
nice to see you and congratulations you
guys both your teams got three correct
in that round
welcome I'm Kevin Smith that's usually
everybody does all right so this is
going to be how we do it how we have run
off questions for this we can do okay
let's do that
wait what's what's the other thing the
other thing is we play knockout let's
play knockout okay all right face each
other so that the camera doesn't look at
bagger that's coming closer come in a
little closer there and here comes JC JC
is gonna be our line judge so the idea
explain what the ideas the idea is I'll
give you a category and you have to give
an answer and then you have to give an
answer and you have to give an answer
and if it takes you longer than five
seconds
to come up with an answer the other guy
wins okay and is it Mike on new so this
category is named a character from Star
Wars go
Jabba Luke Yoda obi-wan Han Leia Lando
but with that Darth Vader flashes from a
stormtrooper
[Music]
it's delicious clone thank you whoo that
was fun man and deceptively like it
seems simple like oh I could name a
thousand but you like there is a moment
of hesitation as you try to think and
hesitate like a throat game I know all
right here we go round two ladies and
gentlemen round two is called tease me
in this round you're gonna win t-shirts
that I don't fit into anymore
these all came from the casual male XL
store DXL whatever they're calling
themselves and there are three different
ones there's a Hulk with the first
Wolverine appearance there's Captain
America with the Red Skull and then it
looks like a movie of his a movie civil
war I think each one 3x or more I think
one of them might be 5 X so you can
absently what happened to last week's
winner you said somebody used well Sean
boss came on the for the first one and
he got a t-shirt and used its magical
powers to finish his first half-marathon
fuckin'-a man these shirts are magical
totems here we go round to tease me this
is what you're gonna win three t-shirts
number one question what is the T
category this is this this time the T
category is just about T in pop culture
t the drinking either drinking tea oh
the world's second most favorite
beverage after coffee
andis gonna spill the tea here we go
number one in Star Trek The Next
Generation
jean-luc Picard orders his tea exactly
the same way how the exact punctuation
it's the question master Andy asked him
in the next generation jean-luc Picard
orders his tea exactly the same way how
and you have to be exact with
punctuation they just announced that
he's getting his own show I heard that
on the Star Trek app jean-luc Picard
like what happened to him after Trek or
something like really where he's just
gonna sit around a big I remember being
in space
he and Wesley you're gonna sit on the
fort that'd be amazing I think it's kind
of cool like when he was done with Trek
he was like [ __ ] Star Trek but now he's
just like I love Star Trek in his back
tremendous number two you're Patrick
Stewart is uncanny thank you
what's the first thing the Disney Mad
Hatter says to Alice at the Mad Tea
Party now you're asking for the cartoon
the cartoon what's the first thing that
Disney Mad Hatter says to Alice at the
Mad Tea Party very famous first line
I'll eliminate a line it's not who you
that is correct as the caterpillar
getting all high hmm-hmm
no looking caterpillar if you will who
played the doctor who ate jammie Dodgers
with his tea and who fooled the Daleks
into thinking it was a self-destruct
button so he had a jammie Dodger and he
fooled the Daleks with it because he
always had one on hand because that's
what he ate with his tea every doctor
has some sort of quirk oftentimes it's a
food in this case who played that doctor
who played that doctor so you got your
pick just pick a doctor
picking doctors number four what
working-class meal is served with tea
just after quitting time famous meal
name in Great Britain just see if you
can think of it what working-class meal
is served with tea just after quitting
time at number five
what kind of waiters serve Mary and
Bertie in Mary Poppins I got this one
yeah other than that the rest of it talk
those were difficult man what Ghana
waiters serve Mary and Bertie in the
movie Mary Poppins and that is the last
clue in round to tease me once you
filled out your cards ladies and
gentlemen throw them in the air wave
them like you just don't care
today is daddy Jimmy V will come around
and collect them T is for tough in this
round oh [ __ ] it was yeah we have a
doctor who question that we did get some
requests that doctor who was not being
served
I like how you don't you you pull no
punches you're not you know like I know
everyone's here at the bar for a good
time having some booze I don't give a
[ __ ]
they better be tight they better be
smart these are tough questions all the
internet cares about is if they're right
that's stuff that's true well sooner or
later we'll get the Internet up and
running while we play this case yes
that's real play as well although a lot
of people online asking about that last
chance folks if we're collecting all the
cards you got five seconds let's count
it down together five four three two one
cue the rounds over put your hands
together man we did it alright Andy take
us there in Star Trek The Next
Generation jean-luc Picard once a future
TV star sorry streaming store orders is
T exactly the same way how the exact
punctuation Earl Grey halt
oh I see so you needed you wanted a new
sentence Earl Grey ha ha number two
what's the first thing the Disney Mad
Hatter says to Alice at the Mad Tea
Party no room no room no room who is the
matter is that uh what's his name oh my
goodness gracious no he plays Uncle
Albert Edwin Edwin Ralph's always doing
number three who played the doctor who
ate the jammie Dodgers with his tea who
fooled the Daleks into thinking it was a
self-destruct button
that would be Matt Smith ladies and
gentlemen Matt Smith we got some new
fans in here a fairly recent doctor what
working
class meal is served with tea just after
quitting time this could have been hard
it was easy it is high tea
oh that's I T and the reason it's called
high tea is that not that it's some sort
of fancier event it's that you serve it
at a table as opposed to sitting down
around like a coffee table it's a little
higher version yes it's a real
misleading sell for a fellow like myself
hi da letto the Beatles called Mariposa
number five fifth and final question the
round what kind of waiters serve Mary
and Bertie in Mary Poppins
I'm gonna guess and say just like Nate's
doing penguins penguins it is the
Penguins all right how many winners we
got we got two teams we want a
representative from each team to step up
or here to the bar what are the two
teams Andrew well well let's welcome
back Sarlacc stung somebody on up and
hello sir and then the second team is
it's all coming back to me now it's all
coming back to me now what team where
are you so coming back to me now
ah okay
are we doing the same thing we want to
do it we can do a knockout round I love
this [ __ ]
all right make sure all on-camera do you
see each other okay so face each other
as each other get my microphone is the
microphone on can't hesitate can't
repeat and five seconds to answer or
else you're out you ready name a
character from The Simpsons Homer Bart
Marge Daisy no no Daisy
[Applause]
you know what there are so many Simpsons
characters we could find out that there
is it Daisy there could be a daisy in it
but you know obviously there's hundreds
and hundreds of characters but you know
there are many characters that come to
mind before one that none of us in this
room know Fahrenheit
all right here we go round three those
good round give it up for our winners
folks round three ladies and gentlemen
is the brats around in the brats around
here the winner of this round walks away
with a screen-used movie prop from the
movie yo Gosar's man there's a proxy and
this one's made of the rubbery [ __ ]
laughs yeah if you were made of
styrofoam but this is the gooey stuff
he's got a scared expression and he
jiggles watch it see all right here we
go
Brock see round round three is always
about monsters the questions are monster
questions and Andy has come up with a
bunch of questions 5 to be exact about
some monsters here we go pens up cards
at the ready phones down question number
one scoot mcnairy married his co-star of
Gareth Edwards film monsters what is her
name oh my god was he in that movie yes
that's where he met his wife or did his
career no no he'd been in some other
things but that was his first yeah wow
man Gareth I guess we should he said
it's a great scoot mcnairy I mean he's
like became a legit actor that movie it
was basically Gareth Edwards like
[ __ ] around with what was it like
footage like going to places where they
had natural disasters they shot a big
part after Katrina they went in and shot
in a town he got permission to do that
and also we talked about they would go
to like a place that had been upended by
the storm that just looked like hell had
hit it and they'd be like oh god but
things came through here talking about
like these [ __ ] monsters that are
consider using a chiral disaster in a
really smart way in an indie film also
he was a special-effects artist he ran
the Doctor Who effects team for when
Doctor
who came back with you know what's his
name
the first new doctor yeah and he started
his career as he made he designed covers
for popular science so I went on to do
Godzilla
yeah broke one that's correct [ __ ] so
somebody said what Chris Eccleston yes
that was the the doc we were living at
okay here we go man number two what
number of the final fantasy video game
series is entitled monster of the deep
final fantasy very popular video game
monster of the deep monster which what
number of the final fantasy video game
series is entitled monster of the deep
number three Oh
Surtur is the monster in what recent
film Surtur sir is the monster and what
recent very enjoyable film who as you
are T you are as if it were French for
on top of Terror
number as a smart persons okay number
four in Jack and the Beanstalk what does
the giant chant about making out of
human bones that's an easy one
it's nice of you to include it I it was
for use hair and thank you now I'm in on
this round I nude three though I got
three up four I'm not gonna get five
I'll tell you right now
in the TV show Grimm the Wesen Wesen or
huisun vaison vaison Wesson Dave ace and
Wesson wrestling Wesson but that's how
they stayed on the show and it's it's
actually not Westin the verson are
human-like monsters based on what kind
of animals it's the depth the Besant in
Dutch means that the characters if that
helps so what kind of grim the Messam
are human-like monsters based on what
kind of animals Jason Mewes was here
you'd be like Oh
and then he would write his answer and
tell you about the last ten episodes as
he wanted to hear they're not I tried to
get a monster of a week show into the
monster section this week kind of smart
all right there it is man there's your
round three brats around monster
questions when you are done filling out
your cards
hold them up in the air Big Daddy Jimmy
Bjorn eight will collect them for you
and then me and Andrea will endeavor to
answer these tough tough questions these
monster questions every will everyone
got their cards handed the cards in
everybody no cards out any card to left
cards there we go about to close the
round in five four three two
Wow we did it man we finished the other
round put your hands together we're
accomplished Route three ladies and
gentlemen [ __ ] that feels good getting
[ __ ] done alright man number one Andy
scoot mcnairy married his co-star of
gareth edwards film monsters what is her
name her name is Whitney Abel Whitney
Abel or now Whitney McNary is it Whitney
Abel Abel Wow um what number I got lost
in real world I was like is that true
look he married a lady Abel that was my
number two what number of the final
fantasy video game series is entitled
monster of the deep be number 15 or we
would have taken X V X V or 15 is the
answer number 3 searcher is the monster
and what recent film would that be Thor
Ragnarok would be Thor Ragnarok in Jack
and the Beanstalk what does the giant
chant about making out of human bones
I'll grind his fee fie foe fum I smell
the blood of an Englishman be he live or
be he dead I'll grind his bones to make
my bread so what answer did you want
exactly
bread bread we're looking for bread on
that one bread and number 5 in the TV
show Grimm the besson or whatever our
human-like monsters based on what kind
animals who we got here birds they are
alien-like creatures fan over here oh my
lord
nationality a single card that we've
just been handed and here that means
there's no runoff that means there's a
winner and who is the winner
that winner would be with three correct
answers Darth Maul rat's arse Mallrats
wins a proxy proxy it's made of the same
[ __ ] that flashlights are made up you
could cut a hole in it and [ __ ] it
gentlemen well done okay man number four
number four folks is the raw round the
raw round comes with this awesome tray
and smoking products right there if you
like weed you like round or raw honestly
I've probably the Apple Computer I use
every day or my phone mm-hmm but in
terms of name-brand [ __ ] like that is
what I ingest that and veggie grill I
ingest the most I would say Lee and that
I will ingest eight times a day diff
eight different joints let me ask you
isn't it called raw because it's made
with no additives or dyes or artificial
ingredients
absolutely that seems like a very
sensible way for one to smoke marijuana
it is and it sounds like we're getting
paid but no or not at all but that's a
good point it is it's better than most
raw just like Andy it's better than most
Wow thank you yeah if I could give it up
for Andy got some fans overhead with the
Wesson rule for raw for round four is
the raw round it's all questions usually
we'd related this week that we'd related
round of questions has to do with one
motion picture ladies and gentlemen
dazed and confused here we go everybody
let's now decide really big off [ __ ] I
saw thank God
here we go number one pens up phones
down the round begins what is Jason
London's character Pink's belt buckle
made out of Jason London's character
Pink's wearing a belt buckle what's it
made
that's right not cheese let's just say
he's hiding it in something in plain
sight I see I see number two what
actress eloped with another actor before
her mother had the marriage annulled I
remember this
in the cast what actress eloped with
another actor I couldn't name the actor
but I can name the actress you just you
just want the I I just want the actress
before her mother had the marriage
annulled Wow it was good it was during
the production yeah that happened that's
a true thing number three what actor did
not get cast after a Richard Linklater
thought he was too much like Ben Affleck
yes what actor was not cast in the movie
as not as a different character because
he was too much like Ben Affleck
according to Richard Linklater I don't
even know this one I'd have to guess on
this one what number four what
expression is spray-painted on a wooden
shack by school famous southern
expression painted on the shack that
they walk by it as they walk into school
early on in the movie there we go that's
the that's the reaction I want people in
anguish
I knew this once and number five the
final question in our raw round
featuring days two confused themed
queries Matthew McConaughey's production
company name comes from what expression
used by his character Wooderson that's
correct it's the initials it's it's
called I get older they stay the same
no that's it's the initials of an
expression that he says is his life's
motto there it is man Matthew
McConaughey's production company name
comes from what expression used by his
character
Wooderson that's the last question in
the round folks when you finish filling
out your card throw your hand in there
wave it like you just don't care
everybody get in their car they
and Big Daddy Jimmy beer gonna track you
down I gotta take them from you but
you're gonna want them to take them
because then they're gonna tabulate them
figure out if you're a winner or not but
we're all [ __ ] winners even if we
don't walk away with prizes ladies and
gentlemen because we're havin a good
time here at the scum and villainy
Cantina here in Hollywood
pullin that taffy like that like a pro
alright man cards out everyone got
everybody got their cards in no more
cards out we're about to close this
round all the cards are in five four
three two one [ __ ] that round it's over
put your hands together ladies and
gentlemen we've moved on we're in the
future let's look at the answers to
round round for the raw round all dazed
and confused oriented questions what is
Jason
London's characters pink pigs belt
buckle made out of it is a marijuana
pipe there we go a lot of days would he
not have gotten that one there's a party
got the eye of the tiger over there we
would have taken just pipe that's all
like pipe marijuana pipe smokey what
actress eloped with another actor before
her mother had the marriage annulled
that would be a 16 year old Milla
Jovovich [ __ ] I was gonna say yeah
later on she married a director that's
right I I could not pull the name so I
was gonna say resident evil lady would
that have counted I would have taken it
from you but not on the cards sounds
like our wedding vows I would take it
from you but not the cars here we go
number four mm-hmm what expression is
spray-painted on a wooden shack by
school oh no that we missed number three
number three what actor did not get cast
after Richard Linklater thought he was
too much like Ben Affleck I saw this in
an early interview it was Vince Vaughn
Vince Vaughn was up for a role in that
film he was part of that whole crew of
young Hollywood's and he did not get
cast I've never ever before yeah
whatever an interesting than exciting
answer no no but that's worth knowing
what expression is spray paint
especially if you ever get into a fight
with Vince Vaughn
like you weren't even good enough to get
in taste confusion [ __ ] a better flight
copy well then you get punched or he's a
big guy yeah what expression
spray-painted on the wooden shack by
school Andy anybody eat more [ __ ] eat
more possum ah
eat more possum it is a southern ism
that means
hey listen suck it up life's bad you
know there's no meal on the table just
eat more possum right yep
interesting number five Matthew
McConaughey's production company name
comes from what expression used by his
character at Watterson and so he said
alright alright alright his production
company's name is JK l just keep living
Jess keep living yeah there it is man
there's your Dazed and Confused
questions ladies gentlemen Andy dug deep
and frustrated all of us with one of our
favorite movies will never look at Dazed
& Confused the same way that's my hope
he's ruined if I supposed to know next
time you're watching that movie you will
scream at the television how was I
supposed to know Milla Jovovich got
married going for Andy he came up with
some great [ __ ] questions ladies
gentlemen a round of applause for quiz
master oh why thank you so much
professor and your McKelvey not a real
professor they don't have our answers
yet I guess we went through [ __ ] a
little tweet kind of oh my god Nate
right there on the heels of it huh well
we have many how many so oh [ __ ] there's
multiple winners ladies and gentlemen
how many got one two three five teams
five but so we're gonna have a five
where it was slap off we're not gonna do
the will do a slap up we'll ask a
question and then they slap for the
correct answer so do we do it all at
once like we do it all whoever slaps
first is the winner
okay Manson we're gonna have five
contestants coming from five winning
teams man one for all of one is that
right no that's no the thing is like
let's see bantha fodder got just keep
living correct it's not like they all
got the same question correct but yes
it's all everyone's just got one right
to every winning team only got one right
I can't believe a movie like Dazed and
Confused you don't study it like I do
you might even get high while you're
watching it I'm guessing all right read
out the winning teams each team send up
one representative right here to the bar
Sarlacc stun that's all join us up here
country we want the burn tree
turn trees burn tree join us up here ant
the father dance the father bathtub who
do come on join us up here three beans
in a cantina beans at a cantina come on
up to the cantina and oh [ __ ] someone
from oh [ __ ] join us right here there
are your potential winners give it up
for him ladies and gentlemen all right
all right so we got one two three four
five we're gonna need to slap the
counter that's what we're looking for
the first hand down
I'll be the judge I'll be staring at the
counter do not scream the answer out
slap and when Kevin calls on you give
the answer okay there it is ready the
what is Matthew McConaughey's character
wooderson's
first line that is correct well done
well done
fat test that was fast man even need the
[ __ ] rest of the question who
intuiting the rest of the questions okay
here we go man round five and round five
ladies and gentlemen is the round that
we name the whole [ __ ] game after man
it's the education round we get
questions about science and tech to come
straight from the podcast education
starring professor and rubric alpha not
a real professor and yours truly and the
prize for this round are these sweet
three copies signed of Andy's education
book and that [ __ ] pretty put it up
for Andy yes what a book if you're like
oh [ __ ] I wish I can win one of those
you can just go to Amazon and pay for it
available right there okay here we go up
ends up phones down and give me your
ears number one in the education round
what part of your body grow
in a spiral there's a part of the body
that grows in a spiral you're not
talking about what happens if you [ __ ] a
Nerf ball no but you are evidently was
the first thing I went to number two in
thank you announces how much poop does
the average 160 pound man produce in a
day yes this is the highbrow a bar that
I have aspired to how much poop does the
average 165 160 pound man produce in one
day did we cover this on the show we did
there's a rule I remember so I'll be
able to repeat to you once we do the
answer sir yeah number three who is the
carbon nano structure the buckyball
named after bucky ball it's a tiny
carbon nano structure that delivers they
use it for delivering medicine in the
body and it is named after a famous
person because of its shape who is the
carbon nano structure the buckyball
named after that was number three but
number four what animal eats the most
meat there's an animal out there
carnivore eats the most poundage or
tonnage or however you want to say
you're like who's an animal out there
ironically a herbivore mostly tamanna'
me hates himself self-loathing animal
that hates himself
I'm sorry and number five final question
in this round ladies and gentlemen what
animal eats the most relative to its own
weight what animal eats the most
relative to its own way the only one I
think I could hazard a guess that would
be that one I bet you I'd be wrong those
are tough [ __ ] obstructions but we
have talked about every single one and
you know just think about for the last
one think about an animal with a very
high metabolism
are those answers available in this fine
book some of them are there's a lot of
poop talk in that book so we can leave
it on the back of your toilet seat and
you'll be learned by the end of the year
and regular yeah well that's the end of
the round folks when you're done filling
out your cards for round five wave your
hands around and here we got a card and
Nate or Big Daddy Jimmy be gonna collect
those cards tabulate and figure out who
amongst us is victorious in just this
specific thing okay I don't want to make
anybody feel bad yes you declare a
winner somebody's like what you were
just like it'll be the victor of this
mall well take it you're gonna have this
moment cards out everybody everybody get
their cards handed in everybody's got
their cars we're gonna count it down the
end of the round it be we're out of this
round in five four three two one
round number five the education round
these were your questions and Professor
Andrew Burke elfish will be providing
the answers what part of your body grows
in a spiral that would be your ear your
ear grows on spinal and for the rest of
your life they the skin in your ear
grows from the center out so if you were
to put an X on your eardrum it would
find its way out to the outside of your
ear are you serious yes so wait at what
point does that [ __ ] stop it when it
flakes and falls off it's a meal free
newing so that's why your ears will over
time continue to renew the skin inside
if people get ear tattoos do they stay
in place or know who gets ear tattoos
that would be the loudest tattoo man
how'd it feel I don't know if I could
tell you how it sounded all right here
we go number two announces how much poop
to the average 160 pound man produce in
a day
well you'll recall the rule is that the
average adult produces one ounce of poo
for every ten pounds of their body so it
is one pound or 16 ounces is the correct
answer 16 ounces of poo and if you win
this game based on 16 ounces of poo this
is a lot about you number three who is
the carbon nano structure the buckyball
named after bucky balls are shaped like
geodesic domes which were invented by
Buckminster
fuller the famous architect Buckminster
Fuller not a lot of Buckminster Fuller
fans in the house people didn't come
armed with their knowledge of
architecture for this game
what fuller house was about him
what animal eats the most meat Andy that
would be the largest mammal on earth not
Bama with the largest animal on earth
the blue whale eats krill which are
creatures and that is the most amount of
meat that we buy anyone I don't think I
would have got that one right at all
whoo
this one though I might have a shot uh
what animal eats the most relative to
its own weight
what animal eats the most relative a
stone weight beating the hummingbird by
almost twice as much it is the american
pygmy shrew whose heart beats more than
a thousand times a minute is that right
yeah wait so it's everyone thought it
was AMI
I was gonna say everybody oh really yeah
well no no ants don't have fast
metabolisms but uh definitely the
hummingbird was the answer that probably
people most thought of but it's the
American pygmy shrew shrew and this
could be the round that nobody got it
right I believe there are two winners
there there are five cards oh there are
people did get one of the answers right
and let's just bring that money you got
five yes let me just so let's get one of
each person our smaller teams out here
Darth Maul rats get somebody up here
Sarlacc stuns I like stung get somebody
up here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] get somebody up
here oh [ __ ] we weren't prepared for
this oh [ __ ] we weren't prepared for the
winter can team get somebody up here and
you got the ear drum one right and it's
all coming back to me now and it's all
coming back to me now
somebody said get up here but they're
your winner for this round put out your
hands together ladies and gentlemen okay
we're there multiple ones right no no
there's one right on each card
what no did you not get anything that's
correct
powder [ __ ] man yeah thank are you
trying to lose no that's very sweet ear
but we do any homework where's that
killer instinct you like no no winnings
for others yeah okay so we're looking
for a bar slap you can throw your hand
down as soon as you feel like you know
the answer we move these so people don't
get stabbed okay
Andy's gonna ask the question I'm gonna
watch your hands hover a little bit
there you go and then as soon as if one
hits the bar we're gonna go to you for
the answer if you get it wrong we'll do
it again
yes question yeah here we go ask away
any what planet are there referring to
hold on hold on Ola here we go what
planet are they referring to in the
title third Rock from the Sun that's
correct man what team is this Darth Maul
rats wins the education books give it up
for ladies gentlemen great job quick
fast reactions okay man here we go round
six is the genre gems round man genre
gems where we ask questions about some
movies or comic books or TV shows that
we love and this week it is Batman
ladies and gentlemen Batman and if you
get these questions right you're gonna
win this fine ass Batman statue that's
broken if you look real close so don't
look real close fantastic piece based on
Frank Miller's The Dark Knight Returns
and there's a Robin cameo in here man
it's really nice here we go genres gems
your questions this week are about
Batman round six question one pens up
phones down
lend me your pointy bat ears because
here we go what actor has received the
most money for their performance in a
single Batman movie my god that's a
great question as they rollin and
it's adjusted dollars doesn't matter
somebody's got everybody be fair enough
what actors receive the most money for
their performance in a single Batman
movie would they don't you don't need
the number you want the actor I want the
actor fair enough
number two what actor in 1989's Batman
had both sides of his face changed into
two-face from one Batman movie to
another meaning which actor was recast
he was recast and became two-face in the
other movie so you want the actor from
the 89 from the 89 movie he was
originally cast and did not make it into
this into the subsequent films he never
got to play as alter-ego that's right
number 3 Tim Burton makes an appearance
in Batman 1989's Batman in what scene
yeah that's what I said oh [ __ ]
like I was sitting there gone wait a
second I know a lot about that movie but
how do I not know that yes he plays a
little bit part but times bird makes an
appearance in 1989's Batman in what
scene I'm just kind of jumped in there
it's hard to get his face on camera The
Joker suggests number four the Joker
suggests what medical procedure for
Gotham City I know what that is
The Joker suggests what medical
procedure for Gotham City and then
number five ladies and gentlemen as we
slide down about a pole and into the
Batcave number 5 according to IMDB where
did the screenwriters get the idea for
the Joker's real name in 1989's Batman
that's correct
according to the IMDB where did the
screen I like how you threw that out
there core to the IMDB you're like I
need I feel for this later on but those
are your guys quarter to the IMDB where
did the screenwriters get the idea for
the Joker's real name that's your fifth
and final Batman question I know when
people heard Batman look who is gonna be
easy but you found some [ __ ]
humdingers man it's I'm the great Dark
Knight detective himself might not be
able to
well yes I'm keeping on brand that's the
end of the round folks when you've
finished filling out your back cards
hold them in the bat air and batten
eight and back Big Daddy Jimmy V will
come collect them and bat tabulate them
but not gate room same bat-time
yeah get a second he's in the bathroom
at channel it's the end of the round
folks hand in your cards give them to
the boys one more card over here one
over there we are gonna close this round
we're gonna break the back of this round
like we're bein in five four three two
one we finish them [ __ ] put your hands
go away gentlemen [ __ ] god damn it I
feel accomplished all right let's take
us through it man what actor has
received the most money for their
performance in a single Batman movie I'm
gonna take a guess it was kind of not a
trick question but naturally he said
Batman movie like Oh Batman but Batman's
not the character the actor played
that's great
Jack Nicholson Jack Nicholson is the
crack
number two what actor in 1989's Batman
had both sides of his face changed into
two-face from one Batman movie to
another meaning which actor was recast
to become two-face I mean I know but you
know let's figure if we could all say it
at once 1 2 3 Billy Dee Williams that's
right Lando himself was supposed to play
two-face ghosts and goblins that's right
well remembered
number 3 Tim Burton make but he did to
be fair Billy G once was the voice of
two-faced in the lego movie that Haskell
movie he got that role in the end number
3 Tim Burton makes an appearance in
Batman in what scene I did not know this
he plays one of the goons in the museum
destruction see oh really yes know that
coincidentally according to IMDB that
was Jack Nicholson's only uneasy part to
film because he loves art so much he
hated to destroy it
sweet but meanwhile he could slash
women's faces fair enough it's all about
priority number four the Joker suggests
what medical procedure for Gotham City
this town needs an enema that's yes well
done Nate this town does need them that
would be the procedure and I if it was a
160 pound man he would get 1 pound of
[ __ ] out of it pays it off
ok and number 5 according to the IMDB
where did the screenwriters get the idea
for the Joker's real name I don't know
this Jack the Joker's name in the movie
is Jack Napier yeah and they named him
after the actor that played the butler
yeah Alan a pure Alan Napier from the
Batman 66 series oh [ __ ] yeah I got it
that's homage to Alex the Joker had no
secret I didn't know names
I always skirted around it they never
got to it I don't know all right some
winners how many we got we got two teams
ready to go ring up send up a
representative from bantha fodder bantha
fodder and oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] nailed it
an oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] nailed it one rep
each come on up give the applause to the
folks that won this round how are you
good to see you again face each other
and the octa whatever the [ __ ] and what
let's do that no let's do it yeah like a
thing they've run off or whatever we'll
do the run off through a little more
difficult category where you got to do a
little thinking I get three seconds not
five as we get closer this would be
three seconds so if you don't have an
answer within three okay then the other
person wins and the category is name a
movie that has an alien in it
alien alien resurrection aliens predator
alien 3 guardians galaxy guardians
galaxy 2
thor ragnarok Prometheus you get the
broken Batman statue [ __ ] job well done
Bobby would I was tough man okay oh you
broke it
god damn it all right here we go that
was round six
genre gems round seven is the
Smithsonian Museum round these are
questions about movies made by a Kevin
Smith these questions are all chasing
amy relatedly star champion I was
feeling that vibe from from Jason
computers so any so what we're doing is
giving out is this you got a full uncut
set of clerks trading cards from the
good folks at skybox man they made these
cards last year they're really wonderful
so this is a completely uncut set of
cards this is like the trading card
version of getting the giant check if
you win the lottery here we go upper
deck good folks upper deck skybox
those the folks made those cards and I
believe oddly enough we're doing chasing
a me questions I think they're doing
chasing a me cards next well that was
why I did this because I'm always
thinking about that stuff marketing here
we go number one round seven Smithsonian
Museum my pens up phones down and hear
me ask thee number one in chasing amy
holden and alyssa talk about growing up
in Jersey and Alyssa mentions the Eden
Prairie Mall where is the Eden Prairie
mall I know you know this I know if I
don't know one of these [ __ ] I'm gonna
check into a hospital number two in
chasing a me what actors character
accuses banky of being a tracer
Banke he's an artist and he's accused of
being a tracer is that correct in
chasing Amy what actors character
accuses banky of being a trace to an
actor says a line to him he says it uses
them being a tracer yeah what actor
plays him what actor plays the guy and
it says say Chasing Amy in the question
twice because you know I wrote a lot of
questions no worries so it's what actor
called bankia tracer in chasing amy yes
number three in what other film besides
chasing Amy does Ben Affleck's character
fall for a lesbian
another feel like movie in what other
movie besides chasing Amy does Ben
Affleck's character fall for a lesbian
same trope mm-hmm well it wasn't a trope
until after chasing Amy that's right
number four Holden in chasing Amy says
he attended what high school the same as
high school the Kevin Smith attended in
real life what high school does Holden
say that he attended and chasing amy it
ironically had not ironically it's the
same high school that I went to in real
life you know my high school then you
know the answer this question
Holden's high school is Kevin Smith's
high school what is the name of that
high school number five and final
question in the round who wrote the song
alive that Alyssa sings in chasing amy
what a great question who wrote the song
alive that Alyssa sings in the movie
chasing amy directed by Kevin Smith the
owner of the Smithsonian Museum which
was the name of the category and that is
the end of that round ladies gentlemen
round seven is coming to a close man
when you've written down your final
answers throw those cards up in the air
while holding them still in your hand I
guess that's incorrect you hold those
cards up in the air
that's like embracing someone with open
arms it can't be done that's true we
will collect your cards well we won't me
and Andy you're gonna sit right here
Nate and Big Daddy Jim and V are gonna
collect your
Ardsley gentlemen they'll go back
they'll tabulate and they'll find out
who knows the most about chasing Amy
I'll be honest with you I really wish I
played this round I would be winning
this right right but it wouldn't have
been so fair do you think life's not
fair man I mean look I'm sure there are
people in here that were like Batman
experts and they won in [ __ ] that's true
so I just happen to know a little bit
more about the subject we did get a I've
been getting suggest the one we sent you
right on where I lost a bunch of weight
as well man give it up for Brides Weight
Watchers as well nice job and when he
won I less time I saw him I told him we
would send him a Jersey and we did and
this is it you down 55 [ __ ] pounds
Jesus give it up for him that's amazing
I'm all right you thin but that is 5.5
less pounds of poop reduced today Andy
just will not let the poo go I know here
we go the question ever all the cards in
let's count it on the round five four
three two one [ __ ] you the rounds over
give it up ladies and gentlemen I said
give it up ladies a joke okay number one
in chasing amy holden an illicit talk
about growing up in Jersey and Alyssa
mentions Eden Prairie Mall where is the
Eden Prairie mall you mean in real life
of course yes Eden Prairie Minnesota
it's an Eden Prairie Minnesota and why
would it be something that they
mentioned isn't that where you shot
Mallrats
yeah yeah yeah that's why it's in there
yes yes your honor I'm glad I didn't ask
that question you would have gotten it
wrong I know I think Wallace they're
number two in chasing amy what actors
character accuses bankie of being a
tracer who called bankia tracer yes and
that would be no k-ci flagging am i Ron
let me think let me think
hold on so Casey's in line but Mosier
comes up first and Mosier brings yet no
Mosers care
okay well we'll have to correct that do
ya scott mosier boys scott mosier is the
answer to what number what they got it
you got that info thank you okay scott
mosier was the answer we were looking
for
go ahead Internet my [ __ ] is right
here number three in what other film
besides chasing Amy does Ben Affleck's
character fall for a lesbian that would
be G Lee that is yi Li XI Li is the
answer to that question when I get a
kiss interesting all the time people
like you did Julie I'm like no I didn't
I did your Z girl they're like that's
[ __ ] worse that's the most applause
jail he's ever gotten ever right there
number four Holden and chasing amy says
he attended what high school which is
the same real-life high school as Kevin
Smith that would be Henry Hudson
regional that is correct
yes Henry Hudson about a captain or
Hudson to be fair we take absolutely we
take Hudson how many winners why there's
two windows and number five who wrote
the song alive that Alyssa sings in the
barn chasing amy we're [ __ ] a flex
dancing like this Joey Adams herself
wrote that song that is correct
that's right there's your [ __ ]
answers and we've got a pair of winners
we would like one representative from
each team to come up here and what are
their names
Sarlacc stuns oh my son get your ass
back up here and number two and number
two get your ass up here man you're
gonna play for this amazing uncut sheet
of clerks cards here are your two
winners for the round give it up ladies
and gentlemen give it up for your
winners okay this is not gonna be one of
those slap rounds put it right there my
friend well then this is going to be the
what is it called again this is a
shutout the first person not to be able
answer is that okay if you don't answer
within three seconds or if you repeat
what somebody else has said you lose and
the other person wins here we go man the
question or the round this time has to
do with Harrison Ford films like
Harrison Ford film go Air Force one last
crusade a new hope Return of the Jedi
Empire Strikes Back man give it up brain
fried it happens you win the cards uncut
well done give it up for number two I
would thought I thought regarding Henry
was gonna be in there yeah you would
think but no JJ Abrams first that's
right okay here we go round eight ladies
and gentlemen is the Kessel run that's
where we do Star Wars type stuff and
what you're gonna win in this round is
this lovely yes drawing of our once and
future princess man Carrie Fisher as
Princess Leia it is drawn by it's the
Prince called the princess and I can't
see the artist's name but it's really
nice so boom that's gonna be yours if
you get the castle run round correctly
cards pens up ladies gentlemen cards in
front of your phones down and hear me
when I say number one what is grand moff
tarkin x' first name [ __ ] I don't know
that wow that's tough it's not like
Larry or something like that yeah watch
AC knows it JC may know it
what is grand moff tarkin x' first name
not grandma Tarkin grandma target number
two in number two folks in the last Jedi
who says concentrate all fire on the
speeders in last Jedi which character
says concentrate all fire on the
speeders question mark no they it's a
statement statement there's Anna gets a
laugh line after that so yes number
three where does the master of crimson
dawn ask Kira Kira Kira Kira I could
meet him that's from the movie that's
from the movie something JC we're not
playing man what solo I know it it solo
in solo where
the master of crimson dawn asked Kira to
meet him and if you know the master of
crimson dawn that's not gonna get you
anything that's right number four what
is another name for the Thai interdictor
I thought you'd have fun with that word
I did I just came a little what is the
nother name for the Thai interdictor
there's any time I fighter mm-hmm your
tie bomber your tie interdictor there's
a tie interdictor it is a class of Tie
Fighters there's a number of names for
it it's the closet.i fighters that take
dictation hyper-technical work
I picked a TIE fighter that had the most
different names in the Canon for JC's
sake what is another name for the Thai
interdictor and number five last
question in the Kessel run man if you
get this you've completed the Kessel run
what city was Padme buried in oh my god
I caught it gas boilers what city was
Padme buried in and that brings an end
to the Kessel run ladies gentlemen and
the winner of this round is gonna walk
away with the princess star wars piece
of artwork featuring Princess Leia when
you've finished and filled out your
cards hold them up and Nate or Big Daddy
Jimmy V will collect him up and then
we'll figure out if you've successfully
completed the castle it has a run yeah
you know I was a big Star Wars vehicle
guy there was a back in the day when I
first was doing 3d art 3d graphics there
was a Star Wars modeling Alliance and
people would build all of the models on
the computer and trade them and then it
got shut down because it was illegal oh
is that right yeah we were doing you
were illegally modeling I didn't know I
thought it was fun you awesome people
show up to your house like we're here to
arrest your son what is he doing drugs
models yes he's making models off-brand
models ladies and gentlemen give your
cards up hand your cards up once the
cards are all up we'll give you the
answers round is closing officially in
five four
three two one we finished the Kessel run
put your hands go gentlemen professor
Andrew Bikel first asks us what is grand
moff tarkin z-- first name we'll health
we'll health will huff will huff yes
have have paint can will huff will huff
fair enough I never knew that Wow who
said Esteban so yeah they got will huff
over here will huff really [ __ ] so you
better get that number two in last Jedi
who says concentrate all fire on the
speeders anybody Admiral Huck's there we
go right there
Merle Huck's and then the answer is you
think where does number three where does
the master of crimson dawn ask Kira to
meet him that would be on Dathomir
that was you got that Jason [ __ ] do you
see you're good at this
I know JC's like it's Darth Maul [ __ ]
Wow well duh hey man if you didn't get
up to see solo that's your [ __ ] fault
I saw it once you see solo at all I did
I saw it once I saw it by myself I saw
it solo though number four what is
another name for the tie interdictor it
is the attire dick no I thought he was
just calling me that was that your mic
tied dick that's right
it is the advanced tie fighter or the
advanced tie bomber I'm sorry not the
advanced Wi-Fi to the advanced tie
bomber or the type on assure or the
tight inter Tector Starfighter and it is
the for extra pod TIE fighter that is a
bomber configuration for you vehicle
guys that was a tough question it was
going to [ __ ] everybody well I I'm sorry
I was a little pause as the quiz master
you never have to apologize not a real
good job is to make it [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
but if it's wrong the internet will yeah
they're getting ready right now I can
smell it
[ __ ] Gaffey sticks what city was
Padme buried in ladies and gentlemen
capital city of Naboo I gotta tell you
man JC
that's the amount of Star Wars you know
is sexy it's pretty impressive it's all
up there there it is folks we did the
Kessel run all of us together and [ __ ]
and soon we're gonna know which one or
more of us that's ok yes is we've got
cards at the table utility got we got
three teams me a representative from
each of the following teams go Andy
sorry laxed I'm sorry box don't report
for duty bantha fodder and any Jim get
up here and on Her Majesty's Secret
Service on Her Majesty's Secret Service
a new one come on up to the bar you're
about to play well done give it up for
your winners of this round ladies and
gentlemen okay man how do we do this
this is Latin this is a counter slap a
table slap a good time ladies and
gentlemen Andy's gonna ask you a
question slap the counter as quickly as
you can we'll go to you if you get it
right you win if you get it wrong others
have a chance and we go we can either
ask you a question or depending on how
you want to do it but here we go
first question what is Pat Mays maiden
name that is correct
Oh give it up for the winners ladies
gentlemen they were like you're a
quarter and she's like no I'm a dollar
strong fun game okay round nine ladies
and gentlemen we are now round nine the
penultimate round blue and in round nine
this is the pot be in the router mouths
round you could win this sign Funko pop
featuring keV himself there's a Funko
pop of me that we have exclusively at
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash but
this one's from the LA comic-con oh [ __ ]
so this ain't even the one that I
normally give out this is even more rare
[ __ ] well I've got 200 so yes there it
is
I'm chef pop man is gonna be yours if
you get if you win the Funko pop me in
the mouth round full of pop culture
questions yes this is and you have to be
paying attention to the world and not
just the things that we all love here at
the scum and villainy Cantina to get
these questions correct here we go
number one Joey Chestnut just broke his
own world record by eating how many hot
dogs at the Nathan's hot dog eating
contest new worlds record ladies and
gentlemen they miscounted and actually
added ten at the end but he still would
have won I'd be impressed if anyone
pulls this answer okay number two now
that he's married Prince Harry is
selling his car what kind of car is it
selling his car you can buy his car it's
a ninety seven thousand dollars now that
he's married Prince Harry's selling his
car what kind of car is it mm-hmm would
you want to own Prince Harry's old car I
don't know okay does a lot of it hanging
out naked
you know those seats need to be closed
out or whatever
these smell royally number three Amazon
just removed baby onesies with what
image printed on them wow this is fresh
it's very new this was front page of
Google News two days ago
Amazon just removed baby onesies for
from being sold with what image printed
on them they're going through a hole
getting rid of a certain kind of product
number four the Jersey Shore reunion
show is coming back we cannot stop it
what is the situation's real name not
the situation's nickname his real name I
took full first any party the first and
last name you want first and last first
and last name [ __ ] what you know this
I feel so what's one of the most famous
people in the world and yes and number
five where WoW is political where did
Paul Manafort by his fifteen thousand
dollar ostrich skin jacket yes famous
expensive New York boutique that was
paid directly by foreign governments
I've heard about the jacket from the
news this week but I've never heard
where he bought it where did Paul
Manafort by his 15,000 dollar ostrich
skin jacket custom-tailored you're
making them work for that funkopop
that's right Jesus all right there it is
folks the Funko pop pop me in the round
mouth round is coming to an end we did
five questions and those five questions
have now been asked once you fill out
your cards
hold them up and the good folks Nate and
Big Daddy Jimmy B will collect them from
you they'll tabulate them and we'll
figure out who the winner is gonna be
you made people work that was difficult
these were all top of mind you would
think that [ __ ] was made of diamonds how
hard those questions well you know if if
people don't want to play with hard
questions I can just make it easy for
everybody no way man I [ __ ] like it I
respect the level of game you bring to
this man it's tough all right everyone
all done with your your cards wave them
like you just don't care all cards in
counting 5 4 3 2 1 round 9 it's over put
your hands together ladies gentlemen one
more round after this [ __ ] man
but before we get there let's find out
what the correct answers to this most
impossible [ __ ] round was thank God
we weren't playing for human body please
have been paying attention this week I
know really here we go if your finger
was on the pulse of the news this week
you might know the answer to these
questions Joey Chestnut just broke his
own world record by eating how many hot
dogs at the Nathan's hot dog eating
contest
he ate 74 hot dogs and buns in 10
minutes 70 74 we were looking for 74
they miss counted they missed a whole
plate I thought it was 64 and he still
won by 20 how much does he weigh well
let's see how much he shot that day
number 2 now that he's married Prince
Harry is selling his car what kind of
car is it it is an Audi he is selling in
the Audi sports car not an inning
yes Ellen is Audi there it is number
three Amazon just removed baby onesies
with what image printed on them and
those would be burning crosses is that
white yes they were selling onesies with
burning Ross yes they were it was there
is a commitment to hate man Wow sorry
going through a sticker that wasn't that
is one of them that is that will I guess
we'll take swastika but they didn't
actually ban those this week those had
been banned before alright but so you
were looking for burning crosses was the
one that they featured and said this is
an example of how we're gonna get rid of
all these hate products and you'll have
to find them somewhere else
fascinating whoo [ __ ] we got multiple
winners number three the Jersey Shore
reunion show is coming back what is the
situation's real name his name would be
Michael the situation Sorrentino Michael
Sorrentino Michael Sorrentino and number
five where did Paul Manafort by his
$15,000 ostrich skin jacket and Alan
Kuchar a name you saw every day on the
news Alan Kuchar al Alan cooter because
they received direct funds directly from
a foreign government to pay for his
custom tailored ostrich skin jacket hard
question but it was out there and people
could have had a shot at Alan Couture if
you got that you got that right
okay we've got multiple winners here it
looks like five one two three four there
is only one correct card among these
because for the cards say Mike
Sorrentino which is his nickname but one
of the cards says Michael Sorrentino and
that card belongs to the team oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] won it man they won the pop
hands-down with a proper first Christian
name well done sir take that pop well
done [ __ ] what's that yes see that's the
whole point of this whole thing okay
folks this is it round ten man the last
round what happens after
this round is we figure out who won the
most rounds and then that person that
team wins an edge of a challenge coin as
the grand prize winner of today's Ejim a
pop quiz so round ten ladies a
gentleman's shirt off my background what
you are playing for is this Holly weed
jersey that I'm wearing right now
Holly weed you go watch it right now
River tv.com we've still got a few weeks
left and stuff pledged by the show in
advance and we get to make new episodes
looks like we're gonna get we're close
right now it looks like we may get to do
it so pushes over the edge in any event
whoever wins this round wins this Jersey
I'm gonna sign the back of it you're
gonna walk away with this Jersey shirt
off my back round round ten the
questions always have something to do
with backs this week and he's very
cheekily has chosen as the subject not
just backs but jim backus himself that's
right jim backus the actor responsible
for mr. Magoo that's correct
Andy's gonna make you work so [ __ ]
hard to get this jersey man yes mr.
Thurston Howell the third sitcoms of all
time Gilligan's Island he was one of the
principal care you have to be 60 or
older to get any of these correct ladies
and gentlemen but that's how we do it
here this is your winning it told me to
make this is the hardest round
I always did I said make it impossible
because I don't want to take my shirt
off here we go man number one round 10
shirt off my background Jim Backus is
the subject the first question
pens in your hand phones down lend me
your ears what is mr. Magoo's full name
they call me mr. Magoo number two what
Academy award-winning actor co-starred
with Jim Backus in the Harlem
Globetrotters on Gilligan's Island
Jim and iris played Thurston Howell he
did the millionaire
and there was an evil scientist who was
who later on as an actor went on to win
the Academy Award and yes he did no he
just won not for I don't think you could
tell you what they won the Academy Award
yes that would give it away
so what Academy award-winning actor
co-starred with Jim Backus hardly loved
charters why'd you give enough I think
okay on Gilligan's Island it's for a
shirt man all right number three what
was the professor's full character name
on Gilligan's Island what was the
professor's full character name on
Gilligan's Island
it's a Jim Backus adjacent yes Jim
Backus would have known it good boy it's
true these are all things Jim Backus
knew while he lived
number four Jim Backus made the top 40
pop charts with his song delicious with
what famous comedian Jim Backus recorded
a song called delicious that reached the
top 40 [ __ ] who was the famous comedian
he recorded it with so in the era of
kinky boots where the stars of The
Avengers the British show sang a novelty
song this song came out and it charted
in the top 40 with a very famous female
comedian of the 50s 60s 70s and 80s
this will be our kinky boots we're gonna
make this into a Broadway show number 5
and final question of the Jim Backus
shirt off my back around
number 5 Jim Backus played the father in
what famous fifties film [ __ ] that's a
lot on ik 50s film one of the top iconic
fifties films and Jim Backus played the
dad plays the dad and he wears an apron
in the movie in what famous 50s
film oh wow these are tough just for to
go on from the top to bottom what is it
mr. Magoo's full name what Academy
award-winning actor co-starred with Jim
Backus in the Harlow
globe charters on Gilligan's Island what
was the professor's full character name
on Gilligan's Island Jim Backus made the
top 40 pop charts with the song
delicious with what famous comedian and
Jim Backus played the father in what
famous 50s film once you've answered all
those questions ladies and gentlemen you
are done with this round hold that card
up in the air and Big Daddy Jimmy V and
ornate will come to collect all right
those answers down cards are handed in
they'll start tabulate and will start
telling what are we gonna tell him the
answers to those very difficult
questions if you were a Jim Backus
fetishist that whole round would make
you nut your pain yes no kidding
although I didn't talk about his radio
characters he was cast as Thurston
Howell because he played a rich guy on a
number of different radio shows his most
famous line being shut your mouth boy
I'll wash it out with domestic champagne
oh and so because of that he got
typecast as the Gilligan's Island rich
guy so [ __ ] a
we got the cards collected ladies and
gentlemen any cards anybody got any
cards left we're closing this round in
five four three two one [ __ ] that round
it's over round 10 is done all right man
shirt off my back round round 10 here we
go what is mr. Magoo's full name Andrew
Jay Quincy Magoo she turned on a plaque
in front of his house Jay Quincy Magoo
John Quincy Magoo did anybody have Jay
Quincy Magoo no Wow deep cuts all right
number two what Academy award-winning
actor co-starred with Jim Backus in the
Harlem Globetrotters on Gilligan's
Island can I take a guess yes he would
win an Academy Award one day yes but not
when he did this no was it years away it
was years away decades it was decades
away Anthony Hopkins
no that was my best I thought you were
going for Martin Landau and Barbara Bain
his wife his real-life wife they often
start together and chose like space 1999
and they played the evil robot people
and they built robots that played
the Harlem Globetrotters and it is as
good as it sounds it's were the watch
number three what was the professor's
full character name on Gilligan's Island
anybody this is a very classic pub quiz
question Roy Hinkley jr.
he killed the professor
yes place on the boat Roy Hinkley jr. is
the answer to that one man and then
number five no four for Jim Backus made
the top the top 40 pop charts with his
song delicious with what famous comedian
I'm hold on so what year you don't know
well top 40 sixties Carol Channing no it
was Phyllis Diller
oh they got Phyllis Diller over there
now the song is hilarious to listen to
because this is what they do you hear
champagne pop right and you hear music
play right and they sip it and they go
delicious that's those and then as the
song continues they get drunker and
drunker and say it in very hilarious
ways delicious yes so it's like tequila
but delicious
yes all right and then number five Jim
Backus played the father and what famous
fifties film Andrew that would be rebel
without a cause
rubble without a cause is what we're
looking for nicely done
all right man what do we got what do we
got multiple winners I see we have four
teams first team is Miss independent
representative Sarlacc stung send a
representative up here right away three
beams in the cantina three beans at a
cantina senda represented up up here
posthaste
and our small rats start small random
representative up and we'll start this
final round so what is this a slap brown
this is the slap round all right folks
first hand down on the counter gets to
answer the question if you get the
question right you're gonna win the show
off my back if you get the question
wrong we then do it again until we come
up with a winner cuz there's four people
right yes there we go man you slapping
there
[ __ ] as fast as you can once you feel
you know the answer if you slap an
answer incorrectly you become
disqualified so many rules so little
time here we go ask away what was mr.
Magoo's affliction blindness talk
amongst yourselves while I do this yes
and there it is ladies on the shirt off
of Kevin Smith's back okay so that's ten
rounds of a [ __ ] game that we've
played correct yeah that's not the
wooden spoon no where's the oh you oh I
didn't bring a wooden spoon that'll be
the wooden spoon all right you're a good
point all right we forgot to bring a
wooden spoon this week so this is what
the wooden spoons gonna be no this is
better that one right here are two fake
license plates from the movie yoga
hosers they were on Colleen's dad's a
car Tony Hale fake license plates so the
winner of the wooden spoon is the team
that did the absolute work that's right
so suckiest of all teams tell us who's
bad enough to win these fake claws we
will find out when that when the wooden
spoon is being calculated now and the
answers are being rushed to us just as
we speak
is this wooden spoon okay okay wooden
spoon winner is there gonna be surprised
because the team name is we didn't plan
for this
we didn't plan for this you were the
worst in the room tonight come on and
there's two of them so well done well
done
two plates one each well done profound
they knew they were gonna lose then what
do we got what's this the winner winner
this is the winner winner and this is a
very serious team right here we saw the
many time
at the table and that would be Sarlacc
stung Sarlacc stung come on up man so
come on Jimmy has your Jimmy has your
your coin and we'll give it to you right
after the show he just has it in the in
the lockbox but in the meantime I you
came from where today Tacoma anybody
come farther than Tacoma today [ __ ] you
know you win a box of Cheerios from yoga
hose man that's all yours well done sir
well done oh my god I can't believe we
did it
we got to the end of another edge of a
pub quiz man joke I have a good time
ladies and gentlemen give it up for your
quiz master the guy without whom there
is no edge pop quiz because he's the one
that actually writes the questions
otherwise I'd be a guy with a box full
of free [ __ ] Andrew Mikkel first ladies
and gentlemen and that is the edge of a
pop quiz for this week live here from
the scum and villainy Kent Cantina in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard I'm
Kevin Smith and I'm anemic elfrid you
have been educated good night everybody
[Applause]
you